a photo op for a dysfunctional family
despite the smiles this gathering is
overshadowed by differences and absences
but can they still rise up to meet the
challenge of our time climate change
boris johnson believes without more
action our civilization could go the way
of the romans he says cop 26 will be the
world's moment of truth and mark the
beginning of the end for climate change
the foes of of humanity are
apathy and political indifference and uh
lack of will and uh people's excessive
caution about what they can achieve
those are the the foes that we all
collectively face and actually i think
that we can still do it but leaks from
the talks here suggest things are not
moving in the right direction ahead of
next week's crucial climate gathering in
scotland
for cop26 to have a chance of success
g20 leaders here need to set new targets
and come up with more concrete plans to
reduce emissions from what we're seeing
of negotiations here they're not making
enough progress towards those goals
protests continue around the summit to
keep up pressure on world leaders
activists questioning whether it's worth
cop 26
even happening
it's useless to meet in glasgow if
there's no clear will to solve the
problem it's essential to gather
international cooperation is crucial but
if there's not a will to act it's
useless to meet the expectations for
glasgow so far are not good i don't see
the will to solve the climate problem
and treat it as an emergency you can
solve it easily if you want but they
don't want to
but the head of g20 partner the oecd
says there's no alternative to keep on
trying the only way we're ultimately
going to solve the climate change
challenge challenge is by countries all
around the world working together and
aligning their strategies
multilateralism can be hard but
if you persist with trying to solve a
problem you will get outcomes
leaders have all day sunday to make
those outcomes meaningful and make cop
26 viable but with some leaders missing
and divisions opening up it may be an
uphill struggle
dominic waghorn sky news rome